CS2 has finally received its first major
content update it isn't big but it's
something we got new skins weird new
sticker Tech smoke changes new modes to
play and oh yeah they finally fixed
peer's Advantage at least that's what
they're claiming is CS2 fixed let's talk
about
[Music]
it all right so very quickly now that
there's a reason to play CS2 again again
you should play it with us you can join
the scory sports's official face at clan
for free using the link in the
description below it has a real antiche
a point-based leaderboard system and is
a great way to make friends and pug with
actual human beings whose mics don't
sound like they're in a wind tunnel so
yeah after months of waiting the big
actual CS2 update that isn't just a
single line geometry fix is here it's
called a call to arms and features a few
meaningful changes and by a few I really
mean a few this isn't an operation it's
not what we were hoping for not really
but it's still a great update and we'll
talk about why first things first the
Cosmetic stuff the kilowatt case which I
will remind you is the first case since
February of 2023 is an absolute Banger
this case goes hard there's a black
lotus a1s a god tier USP what some are
calling the best AK in the game and what
I think is a mind-blowingly cool op bro
I have to see this op I have to see this
op
oh my
God that is so sick why the is
everyone talking about the AK this is so
much cooler and yes there's a Zeus skin
and it has Zeus on it which is fun for
everyone involved it's sick it's a cool
novelty the gold trims are really nice
it's obviously like really cool I think
with Low video settings it will look
kind of bad to be honest but it is
really nice there's also a new knife the
Ki whose model had been viewable for
some time but whose animations turned
out to be even sicker than we'd hoped
it's a nice knife oh oh oh he's freaking
out guys I'm guys I'm not even touching
anything I swear to God I'm not even
touching
anything what the is going on all right
maybe there's a couple bugs I still got
to work out this is the best case we've
seen in a long long time I want to buy
like 80% of what's in it it just it
flexes really well in my opinion how
sick skins can look in CS2 and how
they'll continue to look going forward
as for the sticker changes they've now
made it so that you can put five
stickers on a craft and choose how and
where they're position suffice it to say
the community has already begun to let's
say take advantage of this feature as
for game modes the titular change is the
reintroduction of arms race and while
there's probably a lot of you out there
who just don't care let me tell you this
stuff matters a huge portion of counter-
strikes player base is casual and they
need nurturing just as much as the
hardcore audience if not more so as for
what the hardcore audience got out of
all of this perhaps the most important
paragraph in the entire update is this
the notes under the networking heading
that pertain to peer's Advantage which
claim to have further well fixed it the
consensus already seems to be that it
feels better which is what the game is
in desperate need of right now I myself
have played a small amount since the
update and it does seem to feel a little
better the gunfights do seem closer to
csgo but it's hard to make a real
pronouncement so close to the update
valve also finally made it so you can
turn off bullet tracers which I mean
come on it's about
time oh
man oh oh it feels so much better
it's funny how little things like this
can actually just make you feel more at
home you know what I mean like make it
feel more like CS now not everything has
been sunshine and daisies there have
been serious issues with stuttering and
especially smokes they were causing some
real grief now they do seem to have been
hot fixed by Valve but we'll have to see
so on the whole is this the update we've
been waiting for I think it depends on
who you are and what you want out of CS2
I just want Counter Strike to feel like
Counter-Strike so if this update does
actually make peer's Advantage tolerable
then yes it is the update that I was
waiting for I am of the opinion that we
can forgive valve for not releasing a
full-blown operation so long as they
actually make real substantial changes
to CS2 that put it on par with csgo
right now that's what I care about and I
don't think I'm alone in that regard and
right now it seems like that's what we
got do I eventually Tru want cash to
replace Mirage yes do I want a rework
Cobble or train to replace Inferno
obviously but I can wait because right
now the priority is making CS2 an
enjoyable thing to play which it sort of
hasn't been to varying degrees since
launch but this update does actually
seem to have made a difference so thank
you Val for actually fixing the things
that matter I'm serious there is totally
a world out there in which this update
launched and it was just arms race yay
stickers yay and they just completely
ignored the health of the game I do wish
they'd done literally anything to
acknowledge the cheater problem CS2
might be playable but Premier sure as
hell isn't but as the Rolling Stones
famously said You Can't Always Get What
You Want especially if what you want is
a half decent antiche well maybe they
didn't say that last part but you get
the idea anyway on the whole it's a
great update that we should all actually
be happy about but there's still plenty
to fix so when's the next one thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring the
notification Bell for Unique bite-size
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
us up on our Twitter Instagram Facebook
and Tik
Tok